künstliche Intelligenz provokant
plakativ und klischeehaft im Museum
was will uns das Mäuschen sagen
sprechende Roboter sind gerade im
burda-museum Baden-Baden neben
zeitgenössischen Meisterwerken zu sehen
die aktuelle Ausstellung thematisiert
den Hype dieser Tage künstliche
Intelligenz
ich das Werkzeug oder benutztes Werkzeug
mich aber es kommt diese alte Diskussion
wieder auf uns zu die wir seit wirklich
über 150 Jahren haben das wird immer
eine neue Technologie aufkommt das Ende
von irgendetwas beschrieben wird die
Fotografie war das Ende der Malerei
bekannt ist ja irgendwie auf der einen
Seite KI kann nichts auf der anderen
Seite haben wir Angst vor dem was KI
schon kann
doch die eigentliche Revolution kommt
ohne roboterromantik aus ein
unscheinbares Programm auf jedem
beliebigen Rechner weltweit gilt es als
Vorbote einer neuen Welt es kann Texte
schreiben Geschichten erfinden Fragen
beantworten und Programmieren doch
fragen wir es selbst ich bin Chat ein
großes Sprachmodell das von Open ai
trainiert wurde
ein Programm das auf künstliche
Intelligenz beruht dass Texte erstellen
kann und zwar richtig gute Texte die ist
größtenteils das was sie daraus machen
wenn Sie ein Autor sind dann hilft es
Ihnen beim Schreiben wenn Sie eine Excel
Tabelle anlegen wollen dann hilft es ihm
anlegen einer Excel Tabelle können wir
intelligentes Verhalten in
Computerprogramm abbilden das ist glaube
ich das was bei Jetski zum ersten Mal
passiert ist was dort produziert wird
klingt recht menschlich sogar mit den
Fehlern manchmal drin es ist zwar
autoritären also sehr überzeugt von dem
was es da sagt
aber irgendwie klingt es ja für mich
ziemlich ziemlich menschlich aber was
wenn Menschen die ki-ergebnisse als ihre
eigenen ausgeben den neuen Präsidenten
der Karlshochschule beschäftigt wie sich
Chat GPT an Unis auswirken wird die neue
Technik könnte das täuschen
perfektionieren einen großen Uni ist
quasi eher so ein massenhaftfertigung
von von Studierenden
fällt ein Plagiat durch Zertifikat
natürlich nicht so schnell auf eben weil
die lernen keine Zeit haben dass da
genau nachzugucken und das sagt mehr was
über das System aus als über die
Studierenden sollen das Tour wo ich
benutzen aber sie sollen es darstellen
wie sie es benutzt haben und kritisch
reflektieren warum und wie sie es
genutzt haben Schule Universität Lehrer
im Zeiten wendemodus wie sehen die
Hausarbeiten und Prüfungen der Zukunft
aus Chat GPT wird eine effiziente Hilfe
sein aber wie wird es das Schreiben und
kreative Prozesse ins und verändern was
ich gut finde an der derzeitigen
Diskussion ist dass sie ebenso
grundlegende Fragen noch mal neu
aufwirft nämlich die Frage was machen
wir denn eigentlich in der Uni und wofür
produzieren wir Texte jetzt als
forschende aber auch für jene Student
jedes Studentin fragt sich jetzt ja
wofür mache ich das eigentlich wofür
schreibe ich meine Hausarbeit wofür
schreibe ich Examen wenn das doch die
Maschine kann natürlich kannst die
Maschine eben nicht
auch für Professor Gundolf freier Mut
der in den USA und Deutschland lebt
steht das mögliche schummeln mit Chat
GPT nicht im Vordergrund den
Medienwissenschaftler erforscht die
Kulturgeschichte von technologischem
Fortschritt
wir müssen unsere Lehre umstellen und
sehen wie können wir diese neuen
Technologien zum Nutzen der nächsten
Generation die er mit ihnen leben werden
müssen und Arbeiten werden müssen die
sollten das sollte nicht verboten werden
sollte umarmt werden Texte generieren
Fragen beantworten durch ein künstliches
neuronales Netzwerk ki-professor
Christian Kersting an der TU Darmstadt
weiß wie aufwendig KI trainiert wird und
mit welchen Datensätzen sie weiter lernt
bei JET GPT in ganz neuem Ausmaß
und was jetzt open Airi gemacht hat ist
es hat sich Daten genommen generiert
ganz speziell danach gefragt bei
Menschen du sag mal wenn das der
Anfangstext ist und ich generiere jetzt
diese Daten diese nächsten Wörter ich
schreibe das sofort
klingt das gut ich finde deswegen Chat
GPT so toll weil falls da diesen
Quantensprung zumindest aus der Sicht
der KI-Forschung gegeben hat wir sind
aber noch nicht beim Menschen doch die
Frage stellt sich ist Chat GPT
gefährlich ich bin ein Computerprogramm
und habe keine Fähigkeit Gefahr
auszustrahlen klingt gut ist es das auch
open ai so heißt die US-Firma hinter
Chat GPT ihre erklärte Mission bisher KI
erforschen zum Wohle der Menschheit doch
jetzt winkt das große Geld microsoft
will weitere Milliarden investieren auch
problematisch die Verbreitung von Fake
News glaube dass im Augenblick die diese
Befürchtung oder das sind groteske
Überschätzung aber langfristig wird sich
in der Tat damals sehr drastisch und
radikal verändern nämlich der Umstand
wie wir kreativ produktiv
wissenschaftlich tätig sein können
während die meisten Experten das
gewinnbringende Potenzial der
Technologie betonen warnen andere vor
den radikalen Veränderungen die Debatte
über den Einfluss von KI auf die
schreibende Zunft hat ein neues Level
erlangt ich glaube das ist so ein
bisschen dieser iPhone Moment es ist
jetzt einfach fast allen die Texte
schreiben klar dass da was kommt dass
sowas auf uns zukommt und dass das bald
potenziell alle haben können die
entscheidende Technologie heißt deep
learning tiefes lernen eine Methode des
maschinellen selbst verbesserns bei der
komplexe Muster in großen Datenmengen
automatisch erkannt werden und so können
Rechner auch menschliche Kreativität
lernen
ich habe das Gefühl dass wir in
Deutschland immer noch so ein bisschen
the German Angst haben immer es ist was
neues es könnte Arbeitsplätze wegnehmen
also bis jetzt glaube ich sind mehr
Arbeitsplätze durch KI entstanden als
wegrationalisiert worden es sind auch
mehr Menschen leben wahrscheinlich
gerettet worden in der Medizin als das
Menschen getötet worden wären aber wir
haben immer Angst vor vor diesem neuen
ewige Verdacht gegen neue Technologien
dass sie das Ende der Welt bedeuten die
bedeuten ja auch oft ein Ende aber nur
das nicht das Ende der Welt sondern das
Ende der Welt wie wir sie kannten und
die Welt die wir kennen ist nicht die
beste aller Welt wir können durchaus
noch bessere Welten erschaffen ein
kleines Suchfenster mit revolutionärer
Wirkung in wenigen Tagen haben sich seit
es frei zugänglich ist Millionen neue
Nutzer angemeldet jetzt ist ein schlauer
Umgang damit gefragt es ist wichtig dass
die Kunst des Guten Fragestellungen
zurückkommen dass wir cleverer werden in
dem was wir von Maschinen verlangen wir
müssen Maschinen hinterfragen und
austricksen witzigerweise sind viele
junge Menschen Studierende genau die die
herausfinden wie man denn die besten
Antworten aus Chat GPT herauskitzelt
künstliche Intelligenz belächelt
bestaunt gefürchtet bleibt noch eine
Frage kennst du Kulturzeit
ja ich kenne Kulturzeit es ist eine
tägliche Kultursendung was könnte man
besser machen es gibt viele
Möglichkeiten wie man eine
Fernsehsendung wie Kulturzeit verbessern
kann einige Beispiele können lassen wir
das ist der erste Anfang
ich kenne Kultur ja ich kenne ja ich
zahle Kulturzeit
[Musik]